do you believe that writers should stay
with one genre I'll tell you this I
always tell my writers to pick a lane
and it's not because it's what I believe
but it's because of what Hollywood
believes Hollywood likes to put people
in boxes right it's the same thing with
actors right if you get in as a comedian
it's gonna be hard-pressed for them to
give you a dramatic role it doesn't mean
you can't do it it's just that the
industry in itself when it comes to
writers is really divided into separate
places like there are feature agents and
feature execs there are TV agents and TV
execs they are going to be show runners
who deal with drama show runners who
deal with comedy they usually don't
reach into each other's lanes and
because of that when they meet you as a
new writer they need to know what Lane
you're in so they can know where to send
you that's like one of them just most
foundational things the other thing is
imagine someone coming to your door and
trying to sell you a product and while
they're trying to sell you that product
they're also talking about the other
products that they have now you've got
all these choices to make and you're
thinking okay I'm overwhelmed this is a
lot thank you for your time whereas if
they had just come with their one broom
showed you everything that the broom did
you still might not want it but at least
you understand what the broom is about
right so it's the same thing will you
come in as a writer if I come in and I
say so I do documentaries I do features
I do comedy and sometimes a drama do
drama and I really like horror then the
people are saying you don't know what
you like and you're probably not great
at any of it simply because even if you
think about just spreading yourself thin
right being good at everything
but a master of nothing and George I
have to sell that you're a master of
this one thing also because they then
you're never talking to the person who's
giving you the job they always have to
go into another room and sell you and
pitch you they can't do that if they
don't know who you are or what you are
or what Lane you are if they go into the
next room and say yeah she's a comedy
person but she does horror then the
person in the next room is gonna go what
am I supposed to do with that versus if
you come in and you say
I'm the horror person or I'm the greedy
horror person or I'm because sometimes
people do make funny horror things you
know I'm the you know the Corky horror
person or whatever that thing is but
you're selling that it's like this is
what I am and my writing samples show
this is what I am because sometimes
we'll say this is what I am and your
writing samples show something else
right so those two things have to match
but if you can come in and say I'm the
horror girl or I do the quirky horror
stuff then again going back to being a
consistent writer is getting all of
those random gigs now somebody in other
room says you know what I just got this
quirky horror script and it just doesn't
feel quite right maybe I can hire her to
come take a look at it now you got a job
because they were able to sell you as
that thing if you come in and you say
your five things you can end up anywhere
like for example you might like to watch
drama but you like to write comedy but
you went into the room and you said oh I
love drama and I love comedy and I love
this and I love that so now they're
pitching you to drama show run show
runners and they decide okay yeah let's
bring this person in now you're stuck
writing drama for however long when this
is not what you wanted to be writing at
all but that's what you went into the
room talking about right so I say pick a
lane simply because you have to be able
to sell yourself and people can
understand when you have decided I am a
master of this particular thing with
that being said once you've proven that
you're a master in that thing gonna let
you do whatever you want so it doesn't
mean you're not allowed to write both it
doesn't mean you can't do both it just
means pick one master it get in the door
and then say hey I also have this other
thing and then now they're more willing
to listen because you've already proven
yourself so if Shonda Rhimes walks in
right now and says I'm gonna make a
feature no one's gonna say no she's
already proven herself that she knows
what she's doing even though she may
have never made a feature before I don't
know maybe she has but we don't know her
as a feature writer right but she still
may walk in and say I want to do a
feature and they'll allow that now
because she's already proven herself so
the same thing is true for any new
writer pick a lane so that you can
master it get him get your foot in the
door prove to them that you know how to
show up you know how to write you
understand structure you can get the
thing done and then pull out whatever
other things you want
of your head and nine times out of ten
because they now trust you and know you
they'll allow you to move wherever it is
you want to move what if someone says
well I don't want to label myself then I
would say they're in the wrong industry
is an industry of labels you have to
pick one and if you don't they'll pick
one for you that's the thing about it
right so you can go into a room and say
well I don't want to label myself I can
write anything they're still gonna put a
label on you because they have to they
have to sell you they have to do their
part I mean and the only way they can do
that is by using descriptors and
adjectives so at some point there's
gonna be a label put on you so if you
don't choose it for yourself they would
choose it for you and then you can still
end up going down a road that you didn't
want to go down because they've decided
well I don't have any other information
so I'm gonna read your your your specs
and read your samples and then I'm going
to assume that this is what you write
and this is what you'd like to do and
now I'm gonna send you down that path
and then you're gonna be wondering oh
but I don't think I put me up for any
comedy things because you gave them
three drama scripts so they just assumed
and then they lit the labels get even
smaller if you send in three drama
scripts and each of them have a teenage
girl as the protagonist they will assume
you write teenage girl drama scripts so
now they're only gonna put you up for
stuff for teenage girls and drama you
know because the point is you're
supposed to be mastering a voice you're
supposed to be mastering an experience
you're supposed to be the the expert of
this experience right and so if you
don't come in with your own label
they're gonna give you one
you